>> Okay. So, next speaker is
Hai Le from Washington
University, St. Louis?
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> And he's going to talk
about Precision-Recall.
>> Hi, everyone. My name is
Hai from Washington
University in St. Louis.
This is Jaguar with my advisor
Professor Brendan Juba.
So the problem that we
worked on is Class Imbalance.
So, we all know that
class imbalance is a situation
when one class severely
out-represent other classes.
So some practitioners claim that
class imbalance make
it harder for them
for classifying imbalanced data,
but existing learning theory do
not refer to class imbalance.
So although there are
many methods that
have been proposed
to correct the imbalance like
various sampling method or
the cost sensitive method,
but we have a question,
do those methods really help?
So in our work,
first we derived
the relationship
between precision-recall
and accuracy,
and then we claim that
the large data set
is the only cure
for class imbalance.
So we proved that both
theoretically and empirically.
Further related work in
this problem, Reader et al.
empirically saw that
every metric except
for accuracy depends
on the class imbalance.
Alvarez also discovered
the relationship
between precision,
recall and accuracy.
However, he didn't
like interpret
the consequence of
that relationship.
So first, let's look
at our derivation for
the relationship between
precision-recall and accuracy.
So our theorem is,
suppose D is a distribution
over example with
Boolean label and
base positive rate mu,
and suppose we have
a classifier h with
precision greater than 0.5.
Then our theorem is
define epsilon maximum,
precision and recall error,
then epsilon max has to satisfy,
mu epsilon max is less or
equal than epsilon accuracy
and less or equal than
three times mu epsilon max.
So, in general, precision
and recall is invalid where
the accuracy is
scaled by the factor
of three times mu
the positive rate.
So the consequence
of this theorem is,
if we integrate with
the VC of the accuracy,
we can conclude that with
probability at least
one minus delta,
at least one over
mu epsilon max times
d plus log one over
delta example are
necessary and sufficient to
achieve precision and recall
greater than
one minus epsilon max,
where d is the VC dimension
of the classifier.
So the precision of
the term one over mu is very
important because it lead
to the consequence that
when the objective is
high precision and high recall,
class imbalance does
impose a cost on learning.
That means that in order
to achieve high
precision and recall,
it demand that the size
of the training data scale
by the imbalance.
So we conclude that using
large training data size is
the cure for imbalanced data,
because it is what controls
the generalization error.
So, let's look at some case
study when we really need
high precision because remember
when I talked about our theorem,
we made the assumption that
the precision is
greater than 0.5.
So, we look at
some case study when we
really need high precision.
So the first example is
the ICU alarm system for
predicting cardiac arrest.
So because cardiac arrest is
a very rare event and
is very expensive,
so we really want that
when the ICU alarm system
is triggered the patient
actually need to
transfer to the ICU,
so indeed we want
high precision.
Another example that we
want to talk to is
the machine translation example.
So, in this one we also need
really high precision
and recall because you
can have high accuracy but
low recall if you predict
the rare word and never use,
but you can also have higher
accuracy but low precision
but in this case
the choice that you use of
the words in the translation
might be meaningless.
So, Brants et al.
has a system that's
so continual improvement as
the training data increases
up to 100 billion of examples.
So, it's not too
clear why he needs
so much amount of data,
so we did lay
some investigation and
we observed that most of
the sentences
contains rare words.
And the frequency of
the rarest word in the target
sentence would determine
the amount of data
that are required to
reliably translate the sentence.
So we did an experiment on
the New York Times corpus
and we observed that at
least 1.5 million
example are necessary
to correctly learn
55% of the sentence.
So, for the experiment part,
the aim of this experiment part
is to verify our conclusion
that using large
training data size is
necessary to cope
with class imbalance.
So in order to do that,
we are going to compare
the performance of
different techniques for fixing
class imbalance versus
no modification version
but trained on
larger training size.
So the data set that we use in
this experiment is
drug discovery data set with
about 1 million negative label
and have chose like
62,000 positive label.
So in the first part
of the experiment,
first we stratify the data into
20 folds with about
50,000 samples each.
And then we select one fold
and we create different model by
re-sampling this using
different imbalance techniques,
like oversampling,
undersampling, SMOTE,
and then we change
the model using KNN.
For the rest of the data,
we just change using KNN and we
repeat the experiment 200
times and compare
the performance.
So you can see, for
the no modification version,
when trained on
a large data size
we have significant
higher precision and
recall than the model
that use different
imbalance techniques.
In the second part
of the experiment,
we compare the performance
by different data
set size from 100,000
to 500,000 samples.
You can see that
the precision and recall
scale when the size of the data
set increase in
the no modification version.
So, to conclude, we
conclude that it is
not possible to achieve
high precision and recall under
severe class imbalance unless
you have a certain
amount of data.
And we claim that
the method for correcting
class imbalance
don't help and you
shouldn't trust classifiers on
typical size data set with
high imbalance because
it is very similar to
the situation that you
have low accuracy on
a small data set size.
So, our advice, when you
have to deal with
class imbalance
but you don't have enough data,
our advice is to rather than
trying different techniques
for correcting the imbalance,
you try to explore
some prior knowledge
about the domain like,
for example, for
the machine translation example
that I talked before,
you can try to look
for the definition of
the word in the dictionary
rather than trying
different techniques for
correcting imbalance.
That's all on my talk.
Thank you, everyone.